تركي على رئيس نفسه لم يكن كاستقادها سقوط
مدون العمله المحليه التي قدمت اسوا اداء
يومي لها في ثمانيه اشهر حيث استفاق الشعب
التركي على التداعيات فوريه لفوز اردوغان
تمثلت بهبوط الليره التركيه لمستوى قياس
جديد عند 20.2 مقابل الدولار تراجعت بنسبه
0.5% عن مستوى الاغلاق الذي سجلته امس
ليصبح اجمالي خساره قيمتها
7.3% منذ بدايه العام الليره التركيه فقدت
اكثر من 90% من قيمتها خلال السنوات
العشره الماضيه اثر مرور الاقتصاد بدورات
من الازدهار كساد ونوبات من التضخم
المستفحل اقتصاديون سبعه بامكانيه استمرار
سياسات اردوغان متمثله بخفض اسعار الفائده
والتدابير الطارئه لدعم العمله مع انخفاض
احتياطات العمله التركيه بسرعه انخفضت
احتياطيات تركيا بنحو 27 مليار هذا العام
مع محاولات الدوله دعم الليره وتمويل عجز
الحساب الجاري عند مستويات قياسيه قريبه
قدرت هذه الاحتياطات بما في ذلك العملات
الاجنبيه والذهب باعلى بقليل من مئه مليار
دولار بحسب بيانات رسميه في مصافي
الاحتياطيات وهو رقم سبعه التزامات فيبلغ
بالواقع 0 هو سلبي للغايه عند استبعاد
عشرات المليارات من الدولارات من الاموال
المقترضه من النظام المصرفي المحلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات